c'est vrai que la veille de la guerre
des six jours tu as vu son beau père en
rêve 1,8 a demandé de retourner au qc ca
c'est incroyable il quand tu sais ça je
travaille non mais c'est incroyable
parce que ça alors là personne ne le
savait simple naturelle tu as cru que
c'était l'algérie
non non voilà comment s'est passé la
veille de la guerre des six jours
je passais détail j'étais déjà en israël
et ça met le sustt 1 dimanche soir
je dormais tranquille et puis je rêve de
mon beau père mon beau père arrive en
rêve et puis me dit fais vite des
valises et retourne au pays jeudi au
pays si certainement l'algérie mangement
est belge et ce n'est qu'un rêve après
nous et puis je raconte à ma femme puis
on met la radio c'était europe numéro un
à l'époque je me rappelle et on entend
le chauffard le chauffard c'est la corne
le corps le corps qui annonce légale et
les grands événements et ça se passait à
jérusalem je prends ma bible j'ouvre un
endroit à une page de la bible et je
tombe sur une prophétie délit qui dit
que avant la reconstruction du temple de
jérusalem
on aura le mur de jérusalem et c'était
ce jour la queue leu leu
l'ancienne ville de jérusalem avait été
reprise par les israéliens réunifiée
quoi et c'est à ce moment là que j'ai eu
une révélation que j'ai compris le rêve
j'avais fait j'ai pris mes valises et je
suis parti en israël
c'est pas que j'ai une mission sur la
terre pas moi seulement tout le monde on
est né chacun pour faire quelque chose
ça dépend il ya tellement de gens qui
sont anonymes mais qui font des choses
fantastiques on les connaît pas ils sont
inconnus
je crois que chacun d'entre nous quelle
que soit la religion quelle que soit
nommé
mais alors vraiment les différences
qu'on puisse avoir entre nous on a
chacun quelque chose à remplir ciment ça
n'a pas de sens mais